[Música]
hablamos ahora de salud en directo
américa de france 24 más romero sal en
el estudio mar buena mañana de martes
vamos a hablar hoy en salud de la
pandemia de kobe 19 y las variantes del
virus que siguen evolucionando no más
buenos dias raúl pues es relativamente
esperable también importante empezar por
ahí no el virus va a montar a medida que
se vaya de natura es metiendo es algo
natural que ha pasado que ahora hay una
nueva software de su variante que ha
copado titulares con el nombre de
centaurus ha sido este bautizo o sea
está el nombramiento ha sido un
nombramiento popular digamos no es
oficial pero sin embargo claramente
suena muy imponente y eso está
contribuyendo a aumentar el nivel de
alarma por una supuesta capacidad de
transmitirse más deprisa para analizar
toda esta información estamos con el
doctor carlos eduardo pérez médico
infectólogo de la universidad nacional
de colombia doctor que sabemos de esta
variable que se ha podado como centauros
pero que en realidad en los linajes se
llama ve a 275 realmente hay datos
fiables y estos datos nos llevan a tener
una cierta alarma
más recordemos que las variantes tienen
diferentes tipos unas se llaman
variantes de interés o se llaman
variantes de preocupación y otras se
llaman variantes de monitoreo en este
momento esta variante está en esa fase
de monitoreo en donde se evalúa si esas
mutaciones impacten en su
transmisibilidad o potencian la
enfermedad o desarrollar la enfermedad
más grave para que es calor de hacer una
variante interés o de preocupación hasta
ahora es una variedad de monitoreo llama
la atención que tiene mutaciones que la
pudieran ser más contagiosa que se
describe en algunas regiones de la india
donde se originó y en europa sin embargo
todavía está pendiente de los análisis
para saber si es una variante de
preocupación para tener que hacer alguna
estrategia distinta doctor muy buen día
al osado libre pregunté entonces cómo se
nombran estas variantes y sus variantes
paul recordemos que estas variantes y
sus variantes tienen
digamos diferencias en las mutaciones
que hay en los genes el virus se compone
por un material genético y unas
proteínas que están alrededor de esas
variaciones en las proteínas son las que
generan los linajes y los cambios
genéticos en el genoma lo que generan
las variantes estos linajes pueden tener
sub linaje y se hace una taxonomía de
acuerdo al número de mutaciones o cómo
se caracterizan para poder colocar un
nombre científico lo que se analiza es
que si estas mutaciones tienen impacto
en la transmisibilidad o en generar
mayor enfermedad de ahí se desprenden
los nombres que conocemos como alfa beta
o como se les ha titulado en estas con
el alfabeto griego y en este momento
estamos en sus linajes de la variante o
mika
así el doctor solo como hombre
complemento recordar que la última que
ha sido nombrada era omicron es la
última variante en caso de que aparezca
otra variante tocaría estar hablando de
la posible variante piscila o ms decide
seguir usando estas letras pero hablemos
de los escapes inmunes de esas
capacidades que tienen las variantes de
sus variantes de evitar las inmunidades
de la vacuna o de infecciones previas
que ha sido algo que ha preocupado ya
desde el inicio de la pandemia eso
también puede pasar con los tratamientos
con los tratamientos que funcionan para
combatir la enfermedad o sólo sucede con
vacunas
esas variantes más ese es el análisis
cuando la variante es de preocupación es
porque escapa a la respuesta
inmunológica generada por las vacunas
entonces ahí se crea una alarma porque
hay que replantear las vacunas o
reemplazar la estrategia de manejo de
este tipo de pacientes infectados por
estos linajes diferentes y no impacta
hasta ahora en el tratamiento de lo que
hemos visto afortunadamente es que los
pacientes vacunados es una enfermedad
que tiene un comportamiento mucho más
benigno no tenemos si rangos de paciente
hospitalizado sobre todo mayores de 70
años son menos oprimidos pero las
unidades de gran tensión no se están
llenando como sucedió hace un par de
años entonces es importante saber que
hasta ahora no se ha mostrado mayor
agresividad de la enfermedad que las
vacunas siguen siendo efectivas para
atenuar la progresión de la enfermedad
pero sin duda estas variantes están
escapando y por eso están produciendo
enfermedad al en línea generada por las
vacunas doctor l
perdón no no haya terminado la pregunta
la respuesta no tranquila
la preocupación es ese ese escape que da
la respuesta inmune raúl que es lo que
se está viendo con estas variantes pero
hablando de estas sus variantes yo le
quería preguntar entonces doctor si
haríamos acostumbrar nuestras nuevas
variantes que creen digamos picos de
kobe 19 podemos todavía seguir pensando
en que ccoo y 19 pueda desaparecer
realmente
yo creo que ese es nuestro deseo desde
que empezó la pandemia raúl y de qué
hablamos es que desaparezca pero una
cosa es decir otra cosa la naturaleza el
coach llegó para quedarse es una
enfermedad que nos va a acompañar por lo
menos una o dos décadas hasta que no hay
una vacuna que corte la cadena de
transmisión no solamente prevenga el
comportamiento de enfermedad sino corte
la cadena de transmisión el codec va a
aparecer y si hay inequidad en las
vacunas hay población no vacunada pues
se van a infectar van a mutar y van a
aparecer nuevos linajes eso sucede con
el coach y sucede con el virus de la
influenza y otros virus respiratorios
por eso es importante que la vacunación
siga siendo la estrategia pero que sea
masiva a todos los lugares del planeta y
no solamente algunas reacciones
privilegiadas porque si no hay aquí
además vacunas van a meter estas
variantes
rápidamente para terminar ya que estaba
mencionando también estas vacunas hay
farmacéuticas que han anunciado que ya
están preparando y que van a tener
listas vacunas específicas contra
omicron sabiendo que esta variante
omicron ya está evolucionando o que es
posible que aparezcan nuevas variantes
realmente tiene sentido esta nueva
horneada de vacunas
o sea y hay unas vacunas que se
necesitan que son de segunda generación
que son las vacunas trivalentes que
tienen láser original y aceptado micro
pero hay otras vacunas que son más
interesantes que son vacunas universales
que ya no tienen ese taller tele espiga
directamente sino más alcohol viral y
que harían que la vacuna fuera universal
aquí lo importante es que siga siendo
efectiva para aprender la enfermedad
pero lo más importante es que corte la
cadena de predicción que permita que una
persona no infecte a otras y yo me
vacuno no infectar y a los demás si se
logre esa vacuna si se podía entrar a
una fase de eliminación pero por ahora
estamos en la fase de mitigación que es
vacunar nos aislarnos cuidarnos y
asistir al médico cuando sea necesario y
doctor con estas recomendaciones
entonces lo despedimos por el día de hoy
gracias por acompañarnos como siempre en
nuestro espacio de salud de directo
américa de france 24 por supuesto mar
muchísimas gracias pasamos a saludar
ahora nuestro segundo invitado el día
[Música]